so you want to make it film like Michael
Bay well you came to the right place
although his subtle filmmaking style is
difficult to detect and recreate I think
I may be able to help now you can make
your film about anything and I mean
anything a group of robots
saving the world a group of soldiers
saving the world or a group of oil
drillers saving the world the
possibilities are limitless
when it comes to casting your leads you
have two options number one extremely
hot people and I mean like smokin hot
even if they're repairing vehicles
getting shot at or running away from
explosions you have to make sure their
hair and makeup is perfect actors don't
really have to have much talent at all
they just have to be really jacked or
have nice boobs actually if you can use
the second option and remove your cast
entirely and replace them with hulking
masses of CGI you will also need a
secondary male character make sure he is
a perfect example of whatever stereotype
he is associated with you should also
try to fin every group possible by
throwing in as many homophobic racist
and sexist slurs as you can you read
this we use what we know we don't really
do much weeks aren't the attitude is not
going to speed things up any bit at all
I'm going to ask you to speak into the
mouthpiece but he me notice not Gatien
this is man you know homos in this game
right the bomber no ha ha
still hurts from what you did to it
tonight
that poor man is pouring out his heart
and YouTube's mother does need Jesus
once you really do the production of
your film there are three things you
need to remember number one your film
doesn't really need a plot the people
who are going to watch this don't know
the difference between character
development and an explosion stick with
things they'll be easy for them to
understand such as explosions running
explosions punching explosions guns
explosions pretty much just a bunch of
explosions number two the military needs
to be in pretty much every scene of the
film why would you want to watch a movie
about a relatable characters real-life
struggles when you can just have a bunch
of stone-faced meatheads
kill things Plus who doesn't love a good
old shot of the American
I must say
number three honestly people are tired
of being forced to watch creative color
choices in film do you really want to
put your viewers through that struggle
if you really want to fix this problem
make sure that in every shot of your
film the dark spots are teal and the
bright spots are orange I know your
basic filmmaking instinct will tell you
that it's ridiculous to make every shot
look exactly the same but trust me
everyone will love it if you want to add
in some extra eye candy plop on a few
lens flares ah Who am I kidding
moderations for put coop the screen with
them bad boys and that's it follow these
simple instructions and you will be on
your way to making your very own Michael
Bay film